americans by and large are heading out
this holiday weekend despite high
gasoline prices and uncertain air travel
according to aaa about 48 million
americans will travel 50 miles or more
this holiday weekend most of them 42
million will travel by car and they are
not deterred by near record high prices
at the pump the average price for
gasoline or gallon of regular is 484
that is down from the all-time high of
501 said just two weeks ago but still a
dollar seventy two more than a year ago
and flyers can expect long lines at the
nation's airports the transportation
safety administration says 2.4 million
passengers were screened on thursday
that is more than the friday prior to
july 4th in 2019 before the pandemic but
they are being met with high numbers of
flight delays and cancellations nearly
600 flights were grounded friday and at
least another 400 flights are already
canceled today elise preston is at
newark liberty airport in new jersey
with the latest elise good morning to
you
good morning to you nancy it is a busy
morning here at newark where several
flights are already canceled or delayed
and the airport is warning passengers to
arrive early and reserve parking ahead
of time
fourth of july holiday air travelers may
want to pack their patients because
they'll be going through an already
stressed transportation system in the
run-up to the weekend 639 flights were
canceled wednesday within into and out
of the u.s and nearly 6 000 delayed
thursday saw 471 cancellations and
5237 delays flightaware reported
canceled flights are up 42 percent this
year over pre-pandemic 2019 and
passengers are paying 25 percent higher
fares in just the last 12 months i don't
think prices matter at this point i
think people just need to get away 13
million passengers are expected to fly
in and out of u.s airports this weekend
for them brett snyder who runs aptly
named cranky flyer offers this be
patient and be nice
this is the hardest thing in the world
right now is
you know leave yourself extra time
understand this is tough tough started
in 2020 with the loss of some 84 000
jobs from the ticket counter to the
cockpit so much just happened with early
retirements during the pandemic the
airlines really paid a lot of people to
retire and they now need to backfill
that a lot faster than they expected
they would have to
and so that's why we're in this pinch
right now though pilots these are
off-duty delta pilots this week are
making demands delta pilots are looking
for an industry-leading
contract that contract would
address issues like pilot pay quality of
life and retirement the reality is that
with too few pilots airlines cut service
and replacing and training pilots takes
a lot of time so this summer air
travelers might want to fasten their
seat belts because an estimated 15
percent of planned summer flights
already have been cut through the end of
august
the crankiness is already finding its
way to washington where airline travel
complaints to the department of
transportation were up more than 300
percent in april alone dana
elise i know it's easier said than done
but remember those people you're talking
with in the airport when delayed or
canceled it is not necessarily their
fault take it easy on them thank you for
the report